Понад мільйон українських жінок, дітей і людей похилого віку виїхали з країни, тікаючи від війни.
Але є й ті, хто навпаки - повертається.
За даними Державної прикордонної служби, назад до України повернулися 80 000 українців.
Серед них багато заробітчан, які колись виїхали до Європи.
Люди люблять свою землю. Вони можуть бути за тисячі, за дві тисячі кілометрів,
але коли біда - вони всі повертаються.
Галина Кудь - одна з таких заробітчан.
Жінка працювала в Італії 4 роки, але вирішила повертатися до України, щойно дізналася про війну.
Галина не військова, але це не похитнуло її рішення.
3 Абсолютно! Та ви бачите, я ще й сліпа! Я нічого не вмію, ні зброю в руках тримати, нічого.
Але розумієте, руки завжди потрібні.
Чи комусь помогти, чи кудись піти, чи купити якісь ліки, чи в якийсь волонтерський пункт піти,
ну, що-небудь зробити, тільки щоб бути корисною!
Дорога в жінки зайняла 3 доби, оскільки рейсові перевезення в Україну скасували.
На кордоні вона зустріла чоловіків, які поверталися з Чехії, Угорщини, Польщі, Португалії та інших країн додому - воювати.
Йдемо ми. І тут я дивлюся, йдуть наші воїни. Я не знаю, я покажу потім фотографію.
Чи їх було 15, може, й більше. Розумієте, вони всі в бронежилетах вбрані, із сумками, карематами.
І вони йшли з такою вірою в перемогу - я просто не можу вам передати!
Люди їм аплодували, поляки їм кричали "Слава Україні!".
Я тоді, як їх побачила, у мене аж сльози виступили на очах.
Бо я розуміла, що ми будемо захищені. Вони їхали за перемогою.
Сергій також їде на війну.
Чоловік, який проживає у Польщі, намагається виїхати з Перемишля до України.
Після перетину кордону він прямуватиме до Києва.
Болить мені тут. Не можу дивитись на те, що в моїй країні війна. Мушу їхати.
Не знаю, складно. Дивлюся телебачення, то болить мені серце, справді.
У Польщі у Сергія залишається дворічна дитина і дружина. Однак чоловік налаштований рішуче.
Питала мене: їду чи не їду, що відбувається. Я їй сказав, що немає потягів, і мені треба буде чекати.
Вона просила мене повернутися додому. Я кажу: ні, ти що!
Не знаю, чи побачу. Здається, що я їду в одному напрямку.
Хоча країни ЄС погодилися надати прихисток українцям,
настрої серед місцевих щодо російсько-української війни різні.
Це помітив і Ростислав, який живе в Угорщині, неподалік від австрійського кордону.
Не хочу, звісно, якось образити народ Угорщини, але тут багато прихильників Росії.
Народ більше прихильник Росії. Я навіть не хочу в такій країні знаходитися.
Чоловік також вирішив повертатися назад до України.
Він сконтактував з українцями з Польщі й Угорщини, і збирається в дорогу.
Там мої рідні, там мої близькі.
Чесно, душа болить за ті події, які відбуваються в Україні.
Так, я один в полі не воїн, але нас таких багато - хлопці, які їдуть з-за кордону,
щоб вступити в Збройні сили України, в інші формування, територіальні, і захищати нашу рідну домівку.
До виїзду з України, Ростислав служив у Нацполіції.
Тому впевненість в тому, що він потрібен Україні, переважує страх війни.
Настрой боєвой, як говорять.
Бойовий дух, серце і душа піднесені боротися і захищати до останнього.
Навіть якщо це коштуватиме життя, як це не сумно.
Чоловікам потрібно повертатися. І нікуди не тікати, як деякі роблять.
Галина Кудь також прихильниця думки, що чоловіки мають повертатися до України.
Жінка розуміє, що не кожна людина може тримати зброю в руках.
Однак корисним для армії можна бути по-різному.
Мужчинам я би сказала: якщо ви відчуваєте, що можете бути тут корисними - приїжджайте!
Тому що то є наша земля. Бо знаєте, воно є таке, зараз "Я не поїду, що мені Україна дала?"
Викиньте то! Україна є твоя земля!
Де ти народився, де народилися твої батьки. І ви повинні її захистити!
Сама Галина щодня займається волонтерством.
Також жінці допомагає її блог з аудиторією в 40000 людей.
Коли знайомий військовий попросив Галину знайти коптер,
вона про всяк випадок розмістила оголошення про нього на своїй сторінці.
А тут я думаю, а ну я спробую написати на сторінці, що мені потрібно. Ну, на всякий випадок!
Ви не повірите - через годину я вже отримала повідомлення, що коптер їде. Через годину!
Як і багатьох інших, Галину ця війна змусила ухвалити важливе рішення.
Жінка більше не планує повертатися на заробітки до Європи.
Ви знаєте, я не поїду більше з України.
Я не хочу, щоб моя дитина кудись їхала.
Я хочу, щоб він жив у Львові, щоб вчився у Львові, щоб ходив львівськими вуличками, щоб розмовляв своєї мовою.